hey 42 here one-third of the population
of China can't speak the country's
official language welcome to RIF 4% of
the sand on Normandy beaches is made up
of tiny metal particles from the d-day
landings in most countries the most
popular program on TV is the weather
forecast in 1980 350 corporations
controlled most of the American media
including magazines books music news
feeds newspapers movies radio and
television by 1992 that number had
dropped by half by 2006 corporations had
ownership of most media and today just
five dominate the industry prunes were
served as aphrodisiacs in Elizabethan
brothels in Georgian mama
means father and deader means mother
most of the Italian extra virgin olive
oil sold in stores is not genuine nearly
70% of Cheaper olive oil is not from
actual olives but cut with cheaper seed
oil to lower the price and much of the
product doesn't even come from Italy the
most common street name in the United
States is 2nd Street Main Street is
second birds living in cities stop the
dawn chorus 5 hours earlier than in the
countryside frog juice made by putting
frogs into a blender is an aphrodisiac
in Peru in 2000 it cost three billion
dollars to sequence a human genome by
2014 the cost had fallen to under a
thousand dollars during the first world
war German and Russian troops agreed a
ceasefire and joined forces to fend off
attacks by wolves William Morton the
father of anesthesia first experimented
on himself
but kept falling asleep before he could
describe the results Bill Murray was
once pulled over by Swedish police for
driving a golf cart under the influence
of alcohol
20 million barrels of whiskey are
maturing in warehouses in Scotland
Swedish programmer Lord victory juice
the main developer of Spotify is also
the programmer that made utorrent
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2